pour une histoire de gros sous la
décontamination des bâtiments de
l'université de jussieu à paris est
toujours impossible l'amiante intégré
dans la structure des bâtiments pour
prévenir d'éventuels incendies est une
cause de cancer 10 cas de maladie ont
déjà été déclarées dans l'université
mais l'opération de décontamination
coûterait 200 millions de francs joseph
dans la pierre et à l'ins un reportage
voici un échantillon d'amiante des
fibres qui ont l'aspect du coton cette
matière est dangereuse elle dégage des
poussières toxiques sont les respirent
pendant des années elle s'attaque aux
bronches et provoque d'un cancer
l'amiante est une protection contre le
feu que l'on retrouve dans les faux
plafonds pour isoler câbles et fils
électriques
ici à l'université de jussieu on en
trouve partout à tous les étages
une quantité astronomique sur deux cent
mille mètres carrés le danger de
l'amiante est prouvé aujourd'hui
dix cas de cancer viennent d'être
découverts dans le plus grand campus de
france qui rassemble cinquante mille
étudiants et pour ceux qui travaillent
ici depuis vingt ans il y à quoi
s'inquiéter
eh bien on nous a proposé on va proposer
très récemment de passer un examen de
deux pneus mode de pneumologie
c'est fou c'est justement pour ces
questions là eh oui je vais le passer
et bien sûr je veux savoir ce qu'il en
est vous avez des craintes
je sais que je suis là depuis très
longtemps et je sais je sais quelles
conséquences mans ce qu'on demande c'est
clairement le retrait de l'amiante de
jussieu le retrait complet de l'amiante
de jussieu parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
solution
on a pris récemment des mesures de
transitoire qui sont des mesures de
sécurité où les gens vont devoir
travailler avec des masques comme comme
celui ci mais on peut pas travailler
toute sa vie à longueur de journée avec
des masques comme ça des travaux de
décontamination ont été évaluées à 200
millions de francs
mais les pouvoirs publics ne se sont pas
engagés à payer la facture